ChatGPT for PowerPoint changes
the way you build presentations.
It turns scattered company context
into a streamlined workflow,
helping you create an exec-ready,
customer-facing presentation
in a fraction of the time.
When I open the ChatGPT window,
I can start by organizing my thinking
before I build a single slide.
I can bring in context from connected apps
like Google Drive, Microsoft 365,
and internal communication channels.
I can also upload files
from my local machine.
In this case, I'm pulling together
messy meeting notes, account context,
and other source material into one place.
Once I send that over, ChatGPT recommends
a detailed structure for the deck.
It breaks the presentation down slide by
slide, including suggested bullets,
tables, formatting, and overall flow.
I can quickly review the outline,
make sure the direction is right,
and then ask ChatGPT to build the deck.
I can also give it additional guidance.
In this case, I want to ensure it meets
the standards executives expect.
So I'm going to use a skill called
Executive Readiness Quality Pass.
This helps apply a quality bar,
formatting standards,
and consistent communication
throughout my presentation.
Now let's get to building.
ChatGPT creates the presentation,
building it slide by slide.
It'll go through and apply the polish,
and this is looking pretty good.
So the first version gives me
a strong starting point.
But as I review it, I notice
a few areas that I want to improve,
including some of the positioning language
and meta commentary that made its way
into the deck.
So I can keep working with ChatGPT
right here in PowerPoint
to refine the messaging
and tighten the final version.
You'll see those changes happen
right in line to the existing deck.
Modifying the slide content.
Awesome.
Very happy with the final result.
ChatGPT for PowerPoint takes what used to
be a slow, manual process
and turns it into a guided workflow
from raw inputs
to a high-quality deliverable.